già preso 6 la porta giusta
attivo diffidenza per me lo sai oggi
dovrebbero tuttavia più volte lo testo
che non mancherà dietro si ripara del
gameplay che dovevo scappare dalla testa
gigante si sarà un po tradotto la stessa
di anche marghe è stato proprio perché
se questo video lo raggiunge i 10 mila
mi piace fare un altro episodio con ma
mettetevi comodi preti pop corn evitiamo
che sappiamo
che cosa dovrei guarda fuori abusi lo
spirito con tutte le teste cesa bianchi
luoghi chi vincerà secondo voi questa
super challenge vincerò io a o vincerà
abitare quanto non si sono accelerati
e annuncia importante se non avete visto
il video hanno jersey dal mio libro c'è
è in pre ordine adesso avrò creatori e
paurose a scuola di misteri per i
primissimi che ordinano riceverete
assieme al libro di una cartolina
firmata e autografata da me evitare
preordinate subito il libro lo trovate
in pre ordine su amazon
ecco qua la testa di oggi luoghi
scappata con i luoghi è bruttissimo
vediamo se questo
ragazzino più difficili ai quattro a
quella tra giovanissima che questo
basterà palline di gelato
siamo scappati wow funzione city
abbassare il primo dei è vitale mi ha
superato
[Risate]
wow che figo e l'ultimo tocco
vabbè dai corridoi attenta che lì si
saluta un
tappeto tappeto elastico per poco
soltanto è mai riusciti a passare il
primo stage non so neanche io come
abbiamo fatto per la sam e poi
dove sei sono qua sotto
attento io posso di qua ok ehi ma che fa
quella kimwaki si è puntato su cui è
stato colpito
non so come ha fatto a scampare alla
testa di ogni macchina e si può anche
salire sui muri di nostro matteo come ha
fatto sta che sta qui c'è una kiwa chi
si sta vedendo dietro di me si librava
aiuto lo ricordi con ricordi vitale e
avanti se vai da carlo ci sono le scale
rossa sarebbe detto no aiuto che paura
che ha prodotto ci sono anche chi se
messi in questione di stage a 33 sono
pari a cene tatti
che brutta
e ce la stiamo cavando piuttosto bene
allora che il ricordo giocatore
aiuto più riuscita
no non salì su brava brava brava l'altro
la brito e ora sta andando gli fa
da dove dobbiamo andare fa presto
styling marotta
si
è appreso
attenta aiuto ho fatto il respawn
però mi sto prendendo di nuovo
aiuto dal cielo puoi farcela sono qua
sopra ma ricorrendo ad aiutarsi avvicina
sei vicina scappa scappa scappa scappa
16 16 dove dovete guardare vera proprio
qui dove c'è lui io ti vedo dall'alto mi
ha bloccato qua anche i luoghi mi ha
bloccato quasi
fatte però provato allontanarlo io te e
tu sei pronto non sacrificarti no no no
no ho fatto io ce l'ho dalle scale
dai dai taxi prova forse lo stai
attirandosi devo spostarmi un pochino
sta a vedere una scarpa scappa devi
scappare devi scappare no io ho preso di
nuovo
sostanza scappa scappa aiuto dovevo
andare non capisco allora vediamo se
riesco a guidarti io d'acqua sopra
sitemi dove devo andare
sì lui che sta bloccando la strada prova
lo aspetta da questa parte bravissima
bravissima visite vieni a testa storico
arrivando a chi
non ce l'ha fatta brava per e no devi
per forza salire da qui dalla base della
bozza dello stato cosa aspetta provo a
distrarlo vediamo se riesco a distrarlo
io no un astratto che mi aspetta
l'arrivo un coccodrillo
ha portato dal dramma
brava andiamo esagerare perché no
da time dritta così prova allora ok
faccio affari li
immagino che sarà sempre più difficile
eh si sembra di wired e
donne perché
vi ricordate
e la campanella della bambola la bambola
forse pupi in modo che vi fa mamma mia
che paura aspetta stranissimi
o no
allora vediamo boccoli bar si può
saltare sulla testa di antigua chi
proprio sopra la testa annuncio
prenderti quindi nel caso che ti ritrovi
abbiamo perso abitare poverino
che brutto questo a chi waki per fortuna
ti sei dove sei non lo so da qualche
parte qui quasi una freccia
ci siamo persi di vista dove sei la vita
io sono vicino allo speed 4
spero sia questa è la strada addetta
o no sono 101 radio dietro vai vai da lì
salta salta
attenta qui ce ne dovrebbe essere un
altro ma è tutto dritto a destra la
destra destra destra destra librava pro
che è adesso
dentro quella porta il giocatore
aggiunge
forse per quanto brava abbiamo ottenuti
4 siamo fortissimi guardare lo 64 c'è
provvedimento dia più ma chi vedi
sappiamo se non la casa la fabbrica dei
giocattoli non è proprio lavoro capire
la sua casa proprio non può incastrato
fino ai patti eima demo tipo nella pugna
di aghi maghi ma anche bello
e aiuto dove abbiamo
appreso aiuto mi sta perseguendo due
anni ma chi
può pensavo fosse un vicolo cieco per
fortuna d'acqua riesco scappare ma non
mi puoi prendere da qua perché la testa
troppo girate a
e un labirinto da che parte devo andare
qua c'è la scala ma forse sono arrivata
d'acqua proviamo può fare quadro capisco
più niente
da fare e loro ag informata per tutto 36
finita sono qui qualche sotterraneo non
è una prigione con una kimwaki d'entrée
fatta anch'io sono lì no
questo è un piccolo ceco toma dove
l'uscita hai trovato uno steve jobs ma
forse la scala da dove si notino a
latere perché non era in alto si è fatta
non ci credo come ho fatto io non trovo
vederti qui si fa la stessa katy guido
di nicola gremito visto andare abbiamo
trovato la povera di in piscina comunale
e spero che sia la strada giusta sono
c'è scritto scegli la porta giusta
quando sarà la volta giusta mi ricorda
l'altro zocco che abbiamo provato si
sceglie la porta giusta ma sono
tantissime come ci andiamo
proviamo questa
se andate quella sia una giusta wow
brava come abbiamo fatto non lo so 5 non
sei riuscito a passare ma dobbiamo salta
si aspetta nello stage 5
nuovo una corda o una trappola attenta
che piano di a chi vuol mazzi e ci sono
anche delle trappole non l'avevo visto
che brutti
[Musica]
nonno diventa molto più difficile adesso
ci sono varie punte che girano come si
fa con queste trappole
per non sia la strada giusta
queste trappole come funzionano devi
stare molto molto attento non farti
prendere
diventa sempre più difficile e parole
divertente anche se un po paura ma noi
piacciono le cose che fanno fa non mi
dire che questo vicolo cieco
prima di processarmi dice a noi
piacciono né cosa che avrebbe paura è
infatti avete già preso il libro storie
paurose alcuna di mister ci saranno
varie creature che vi piacciono molto e
che per creatura preferite vi do un
piccolo una delle creature un lupo
mannaro non vi ricordano però ma ne vide
esistono vari spoiler in questi ultimi
video ci sono vari spoiler quindi se
volete saperne di più ma deve avere
anche gli altri video come faccio a
passare d'acqua
vabbè ci provo c'è una di vaghi ma aiuto
se riesco a superare questo stage sarà
un miracolo c'è una luce qui dobbiamo
dare qui forza si states e non ci credo
bollito ma tu come vai per prepararti
breve io sono troppo forte
parlava e di quello di la strada giusta
ok penso non paura di essermi persa
no io non avevo tutti questi corridoi
non c'è forse quella a me che non sono
tornata all'entrata
si
no
dai dorsi trovato la porta la lega pro
si
guarda te attivo diffidenze reato qui
wow è difficilissimo dei fantasmi sembra
uno stage di supermario questo
stranissimo
primissimo
wow sedici sono i mattoncini tipo super
mario
ovviamente antigua chi non manca mai
eccone qua 500mila o no adesso ma si
sono messi tutti lì a una porta
[Applauso]
sono un po arrabbiati no è difficile
credo
attento attento punto tetto non farti
prendere dagli aghi wajid adesso avanti
laggiù c'è un mostro finale mi sembra
aiuto
[Musica]
non capisco dov'è ok via ci sei
sono dietro di te
wow in questi giochi difficilissimi
invece di essere in competizione gli
mettiamo in squadra perché tra i figli
corre perché sono tutti qua vicino la
porta no li dobbiamo distrarre in
qualche modo attento attento tentò
ma chi ne manca uno da distrarre e
scompare dai dai vieri ok vai vai sì o
non ci credo allora bisogna stare
attenti a non bruciare con anti
attento perché anche i fantasmi ti
inviano è veramente difficilissima
questa è proprio difficile allora qui
possiamo salvare credo per 80 gli archi
wang yi quest'anno sparando vento o no è
qua come bastiamo
no mista trascinato devi stare attento
di riscaldare in continuo successo gli
interessa fare il vento non solo dietro
vivrai puoi farcela nostro dietro di te
ok abbiamo fatto e ora dobbiamo
scegliere la strada giusta o
proviamo a vedere se possiamo attraverso
qua è veramente difficili l'uomo fatto
seguiamo gli altri avevi scompaiono dopo
un po mi
sono dovuto
io sono solo un porto da invitano poi
forse l'ho lasciato mi piace per portare
fortuna vitale e compito ne
dovrebbe farcela e famiglia
e che cos'è questo adesso
sembra un movimento in lava e ci sono
anche diecimila trappole a
è diventato proprio contro la trama
perché mi spingeva il vento di voti
stiamo venuto strano no
ok riproviamo ma è veramente su una
rigidissima queste skyroom
infatti trascina bisogna saltare saltare
il fattore il fattore così non viene
trascinato dalle carte in continuazione
per quello che sto facendo wow queste il
plume davvero difficoltà 10 è fighissimo
quasi sono tutti questi oggetti che
volano no vabbè
possibile bisogna stare super attenti no
mi ha soggiornato
ragazzi portavalori sono postare questo
stage strappo difficile ma se questo
video raggiunge i 10 mila mi piace
riproteggerli altro video e vi ricordo
di pre ordinarie ricordino
di me così riceverete anche la cartolina
firmata solo per i primi che ordinano il
libro
ha detto qui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video il canto su quella
che preferite le braccia